Jack we talked with filmmaker joe wilson
of the vampire law and we did a video
interview series with him and he was
adamant that no one can make a viral
video hmm what's your take on that yeah
I don't think well I think it's probably
the same thing about like you know like
no one can necessarily go out and make a
hit for you know go out make a monster
hit like that's what that's what they
want you to do go out make something
uber successful but I don't think you
can necessarily manufacture something to
be viral I think it's like the thing
about it's like I've always said you
can't something that's is cool because
it is the second anybody tries to be
cool it's it's automatically uncool you
know like straight away but you can tell
when somebody's trying to manufacture so
to try to create something or engineer
something to be viral I think most
people will smell that as being
inauthentic I think the thing that
creates a viral thing is something that
somebody feels that they've captured
something and then just has to share it
because whatever it is about that thing
is so weird or so special or so whatever
and I think most people can detect if
something is reverse engineered to be at
that idea of a reverse engineering is
something that's thrown around in this
digital space like you cannot reverse
engineer a viral video all you can try
to do is is create something that is
real or interesting enough and hope that
it becomes viral I think I don't know
I'd be interesting to find out who's
like sat down and like you know
strategically made something and if it
went viral if they would even reveal
that information like ha ha ha we got
you we made this like Frankenstein you
know but I don't know i don't personally
I don't think it's that's that's the way
to do it what's your response to people
who say oh you choose for kids I mean I
think it's for kids now I think it is I
think it's I think most of what's on in
the YouTube space that's popular is is
aimed at kids but also I think the
problem has been is that in the last you
know couple of generations
media any all media has sort of been
made for specific age group so that
literally wasn't the case when I was a
kid you know when I was kid growing up
in the 70s you watched what adults
watched you know what I mean it was
there was there were only a handful of
channels there's only so much
programming is nothing compared to
what's out there now so if your parents
watched all in the family or mash which
which bike imperil Rhoda were Mary Tyler
Moore Bob Newhart any of those shows
that by comparison would be considered
adult shows there wasn't any Nickelodeon
there wasn't anything there wasn't
Hannah Montana there wasn't you know any
of the stuff that's like targeted so I
think what happened is that kids became
the beneficiary of watching stuff that
wasn't necessary and you ended up
reaching for that or you ended up i
would just remember thinking like wow I
that's what they don't I want to be
there I want to that's that's what it's
going to be like when I'm you know going
out or dating or married or having a job
that's going to be I think I think
that's a good thing and a healthy thing
and I think that there's a lot of
material that plays down to kids and
then kids stay in that sort of you know
sort of stunted place so yeah YouTube is
always going to be filled with you know
I think my sis my wife says somebody's
stuck like cinnamon up their ass or
something like that or two ate or drank
cinnamon or something and that's got 80
truly but that's the that's the that's
the content somebody drinking like a jar
of cinnamon or something I probably
sound super all because this was
probably like has eight Jillian hits but
that is different from we know an
episode of all the family and be
interesting to see if we can graduate
from cute kittens and people farting
fire to something that actually has
that's worth watching over 20 seconds
that actually it's interesting and
informative and entertaining I think you
can be that controlled YouTube can be
that but right now it's in its infancy
in a lot of ways do you think though
that's a sentiment
I mean most of his kids have been around
for some time the 11th what do thanks
pretty much changed and they may be want
something that's lighter like when I was
growing up there was a show family
Christina's family rate it was but I
wondered that's too heavy now because
the world is actually a much heavier
places Mason's maybe although you know
when when you know in the 70s we were
like I remember we're still in Vietnam
we still had Watergate the country was
essentially I mean that there at the
time that birth like the last grade
period of cinema you know are
everybody's you know the consensus as
the seventies was the last Golden Age
was the time of them that they are
probably one of the darkest periods in
this country in terms of people's sort
of bubble bursting opal it whether the
president is a crook and you know the
Warren we're losing a war first war and
it's for what and and although you know
Afghanistan and Iraq make you know
Vietnam looked like nothing
comparatively so maybe it is i don't
know that i think there's always been
escapism people always want you know
whether it's during the Great Depression
people wanted you know musicals to
disappear you know into but I also feel
that if it only is that that that the
salt is sort of like the the collective
intelligence level just gets lowered and
lowered and lower until we become like
you know like like Mike judges feel like
idiocracy which is an underrated movie
or you just become like this blob with
like you know sitting in front of a
monitor which is just like you know
violence and porn and having like you
know liquid cheese that into your mouth
I mean you can that's where it's going
you know where we're going into this if
you don't have any real stimulus and
that doesn't mean it has to be heady you
know that's so tarik entertainment if
it's just like you can still be funny
and smart they can still be action and
smart then you become brighter it's like
if you only read if you only ever read a
comic book that's the level of your
literature that's your that's death
unless you're you know a genius if what
you take in informs what you what you
like and what you put out and so you
have to digest something
of substance in order to be substantive
in your own way I think you know that's
my thinking on what's your process for
creating each episode of trailer image
and tell us more about relatives Oh
trailer hitch is like the you know
trailer hitch is just something that I
just super enjoy doing mostly because
Allen Havey who plays kind of crotchety
uncle al at somebody great actor great
comedian you know who's been in on
everything from you know Curb Your
Enthusiasm to Louie and he had his own
show night after night with Allen Havey
which was sort of like the evolution of
the David Letterman Show really
interesting and he'd done him he's a
he's at the improv lazy great great
funny comedian and actor I've known him
forever and he's a hardcore movie geek
but he's also a generation older than
myself and we've always had this sort of
like I don't know if it's a sort of a
collision of generations but we've
always had this banter whenever we go
see a movie together which we do we
watch a movie together there's this
thing that happens and I don't pretend
to be a comic like Alan I mean Alan is a
professional comedian and I prefer to be
sort of the straight man to his to his
comic you know ability so really it just
becomes about him kind of letting it rip
with these kind of philosophies or
attitudes about a John or whether it's a
zombie movie or a vampire movie or what
he thinks is I like giving this next in
this episode of world wars we did on
world war z which is the brad pitt sort
of epic zombie movie coming out based on
the book which is a whole world you know
swarming with zombies and we watched
that trailer you know allen's uncle al's
response to zombies zombies don't run
you know zombies are slow and
disoriented and remember in the old days
when zombies were just sort of stumbling
and I'm trying to explain to him as a
slightly younger viewer that since like
28 days later zombies run and that it's
not just by walking stumbling and so
this whole sort of natural banter kind
of comes out as we watch these these
trailers and
it's very loose it's very very
improvised what he does is we decide on
a trailer that we want to review or not
even review really just kind of just
observe and comment on and then Allen
goes home and essentially sort of bullet
points almost like punch lines that he
knows what he's going to get into and
then I just sort of set it up and this
like really react to what he says
because what he said what he tends to
say is usually fairly outlandish so all
I have to do is go huh what you know I
basically like by Abbott to his Lou
Costello he can just go crazy and I'll
just go give a look and that's really
that's really how we do it so we just
kind of literally we come into this room
here and we set up like just two mics
and we plug in and we put earphones we
share your phones we look at the trailer
on a laptop and then we just let it run
and then we just we run it like three or
four times and we just do it and then I
just end up editing the best bits
together and then we send it to an
animator all of her dear who was
actually my art director on some guy who
kills people he did all the
illustrations all the comic book
illustrations and some guy and he
animates it for so he animates it to the
audio track and then we sort of just
come back here and put it all together
but it's a it's fun it's like it's not
so much scripted as just sort of a
recorded conversation or sometimes a
rant you know sometimes so you know he
had a funny take on people that watch
the hobbit like they all emo root and
they smell funny we couldn't get a job
at the Renaissance
or something like that right so anyway
yeah yeah what's so funny The Hobbit you
know the thing is is that the hobbit
it's so interesting we talked about
YouTube we did this episode on the
hobbit and I'm a Lord of the Rings fan
you know and I I'm a big fan and and
it's interesting because uncle al's take
on the Hobbit is exactly what you're
talking about what is this you know what
are these dwarves and elves and what is
they and it's like it's like an old like
like like very much like an Archie
Bunker like it just a sort of like a
semi ignorant character who has no
problem like you know pontificating and
spouting whatever even if it doesn't
really know about it or even if he does
know about it but so many hobbed fans
are Lord of the Rings fans or like took
offense but like I hate uncle Alan he
doesn't know how dare you say anything
it's like you know it's a cartoon you
know it's not it's not like it's not
like somebody coming out and and it's a
comedy piece so it's interesting to see
how passionate you know for me like you
love something it's okay to make fun of
it I mean it's actually better than make
fun of something that you love but it's
interesting to see how protective people
are a bit so um I'm keep seeing
different comments some people are like
take it easy this is really funny you
know this is not meant to offend Lord of
the Rings fans and I'm constantly saying
hey look i'm a fan i know you know Uncle
Al is just a character you know you know
so it's interesting Frank so you apply
to these yeah I do you know it's funny i
ordinarily I wouldn't and and but part
of the part of the whole YouTube
experience and again i'm a newbie in
this world is sort of the communication
or engagement I think that's one of the
things that's different about television
are certainly different from television
is that there is a communication that
goes on between the people who make the
shows and the people who watch the shows
in that on any given YouTube videos
obviously million comments if something
is interesting or inflammatory whatever
people comment and YouTube actually
encourages the people who make the
videos at least for the premium channels
to engage because that that's part of
the experience is
you know hey you know this is what we
met or you know like or thanks for some
some people just leave very nice
comments here like thanks you know for
watching and you know next week we're
going to do this movie and so I think
that's part of that world but i'm so
used to movies we're basically you know
making a movie you put it out there and
maybe you read a couple of reviews and
as long as somebody doesn't send you you
know dog in the mail or so or a
hate letter or something then that's
basically it that's the end of the
communication you know so so yeah jack
since you say you are new to youtube i'm
not sure if you remember back in my
babyy 2007 2008 when it seems like it
was easier to get views it's a very
competitive space now and i know we
talked about you know briefing what are
you coming up against cuz you're you
know your trailer has just gotten a lot
of views i mean it's not easy to get get
one that has like 18,000 yeah well yeah
it's uh it's interesting i think that
you know you can put because this is a
company the benefit of doing something
at a company is that the company you
know we'll have some marketing money to
promote so there's there's money in
house or in the company to promote
certain things and you sort of have this
not like a bottomless bucket of money
you just have to say okay then taking a
little bit of money and promote this
episode of trailer hitch or this episode
of badass digest or what have you and
not everything gets the same sort of
marketing push so something that has a
little bit of marking behind it so i can
independ- have some money to submit to
festivals or some money to make a poster
or even if you have a little bit of
money to like book a theater and screen
it for one night that gives you the edge
over over a filmmaker who has nothing
and it's just sort of hoping that
somebody discovers their movie but i
don't know i think it's infinitely I
think it's infinitely competitive I
think it's like worse than any other
media platforms worse than TV's worse
the movies simply because anybody
anybody can put something on YouTube so
it's as ocean or this galaxy of
of stuff that means that there's like
probably tons of really cool stuff out
there there's also tons of really bad
stuff out there and then it becomes like
well how does a viewer including myself
how do you find it how do you how do you
find it and you relying upon somebody to
point you in that direction I don't
think I don't think there are many of us
who necessarily click on something
because we see an ad for a video usually
it's somebody says hey like check this
out like or you got to see this or maybe
if you're searching for something you
can in a search bar but it is this sort
of random sort of very sort of like
check this app thing and I don't know I
AXA submiss it's sort of a mystery to me
I mean I think of you to put your video
up on its main page which is the
equivalent of like you know being on the
cover of a magazine then you're
guaranteed to get more clicks but i
don't know i don't i just sort of hope I
mean the philosophy has always been if
you make great content that it will find
an audience and I think I have to
believe in that because that's the only
thing I can really control like and that
goes for any weather making a film or TV
show or whatever you cannot control what
an audience is going how an audience is
going to react what they're going to
come and even if you make a big movie
and you advertise the out of it and
you spend 80 zillion dollars on TV
commercials and billboards and you know
magazine ads that doesn't mean on Friday
night that you're you know you can't
literally pick them up with a forklift
and put them into the theater you still
there's this intangible thing about like
well as raining I don't want to go you
know like so it's a weird thing i don't
i don't know i just i all i can do is
make hopefully make something that's i'm
happy with and hopefully it gets shared
enough so that people get to know about
it and watch it you know but I don't
know I'd really don't know it's so much
stuff out there so tell us about YouTube
how do you find yourself in this space
it's weird I'm suddenly a suit which is
very alarming sometimes to be on the
other side of the table it's funny
because in the first couple of weeks
here you know i'm i'm the lead
programmer or the lead created executive
for cinefix even though i do direct
trailer hitch and i do direct badass
digest which is more instinctive a thing
for me to go out and make the shows and
edit the show's than it is for me to
preside an executive position even
though that's my role I've never been in
more meetings in my life you know that's
a lot there's a lot of you know here's
the funny thing here's the thing that I
think is very interesting every meeting
I ever went to or I pitch something
whether it was a film idea or a
television idea you know I've probably
spent the whole week at least prepping
for this meeting and you go in there and
it's you care so much and you're sitting
there with these people on the other
side of the desk and you're pitching
your thing and then you know the odds
are that nine times out of ten you know
and no one says hey you got a deal I
mean then never I mean I think once in
my entire career once or twice my Tiger
did I actually pitch something that
actually got like picked up I was saying
this to my wife I wonder if I wish I had
calculated wish I had the nerve to write
down every meeting I've ever been to as
a filmmaker going in to try to get
something done because it's probably
millions of them and so the the
percentage is crazy you know you're
always there's so many things that go
nowhere all right so the point is now
I'm on the other side just for this year
and people are coming in to pitch their
stuff and now I'm suddenly one of these
jerk-offs on the other side of the table
you know listening and what i realize is
that all those times that I pitched
something that it didn't get picked up
and I took it personally where I was
like oh they don't like me or my ideas
not good enough or I suck or whatever
it's like the least it's the most
impersonal thing in the world because an
executive is got so much crap so much
that's what I do is go to meetings all
day long there's so many things that
they're dealing with that what you
consider the most important part of the
day which is
pitching this thing is like a blip to
the executive so unless what you're
offering is exactly this it's like every
production company or every studio has
like a couple of like puzzle pieces that
it's very specific shape puzzle pieces
they're looking to fit and if what
you're pitching doesn't fit exactly this
and pick those buttons it's a no it's
going to be a note every time and I
always was like oh this is I'm so
depressed and it's not that at all it's
just that I suddenly am able to see that
number one second if don't really care
about your dreams and your hopes and how
important the ideas to you all i care
about is whether or not what you're
selling fits exactly whatever their
little thing is that they're trying to
do and maybe they don't even know what
that is and I found myself in the first
few weeks I still do it trying to tell
to the people who are pitching that I'm
not one of these guys like I'm you you
know it's very hard to do in a meeting
to say well you know you might think I'm
this suit but I'm actually more you than
I am this thing that you think i am and
i am so deathly afraid of people
perceiving me as this you know part of
the establishment yeah yeah but it is a
crazy it is like two separate points
just two different universes operating
on the executive side and to a certain
degree i understand why it's so little
gets done really because there's a lot
of weighing of is this worth doing and
is this going to yield this result and
is this going to how this going to
impact the brand in the company and all
this like hesitation because there's so
much money at stake whereas when you're
a creative person all you're interested
in doing is birthing this idea and
that's what's that's what feeds the
creative person what feeds the executive
is that their job is secure and that
they don't make up bonehead decision
that gets them fired and that whatever
they put their name on is successful in
financial terms whereas a creative
person sure they want to be rich and
famous and all that you know but
for the most part it's always about is
is this idea
going to be created in a way that
satisfies me as an artist you know and
at least that's where that's how I think
about it and so it's like wearing this
to different house it's like being
Jekyll and Hyde or something it's like
this weird very strange thing to do in
hobbit people versus yeah yeah yeah it's
it's but it's a it's given me an insight
into the it's sort of like someone like
it's like behind the curtain you know
like eight I never would have known how
I mean I always knew how it worked but I
never really stepped in the shoes of an
executive nor that i really want to I
think part of it has to do with me not
wanting to be that executive that I
wanted to assassinate you know and
there's more of those than there are the
kindly you know empathetic interesting
executive so if I'm going to be one of
those I would prefer to be the latter
just so that you know I'm you know well
thought of during this process you know
but it's a very it's a very unique
position to be in Jack I believe on our
show from courage when you came into the
studio you talked about Orson Welles
briefly and you talked about how he
mentioned this 9010 rule about
filmmaking and that ninety percent of it
is hustling and ten percent of it as
creativity you know in following Orson
Welles story recently I've become very
intrigued with him what do you think it
was that was his sort of downfall aside
for maybe addiction or something I mean
he was basically handed the keys or at
our young age he was sort of a child
prodigy and things didn't turn out as
you would think that they would in hand
for me yeah no Orson Welles his story is
a is a really interesting one it's funny
because i think i remember in a spike
lee interview where they asked him why
he was so into being a businessman and
why at the dining at the time he had a
store and all these things and he was
making commercial and he said something
about he never wanted to wind up selling
wine as an old man and which is what
wills end up doing basically you know
kind of shell
maybe selling wine as a cat as a
personality and a commercial as opposed
to making all the films that he should
have been allowed to me in fact I think
Wells is quote about 90% hustling and
ten percent creativity and filmmaking
sprouts but I think he actually probably
even said it was less Bobby said it was
ninety-five percent hustling but I yeah
I think it's interesting i think that
people resented him from the beginning
because he did he was given this this
sort of creative autonomy that nobody
got ever I mean he came into town as a
radio celebrity and was given by RKO you
know carte blanche like make anything
you want as long as it's this budget
star in it write it however you want
we're gonna give you any notes just make
it and you've got all these directors
who had been in town you know I've been
making film since the silence for 25
years and they're like who's this little
kid who gets 20-something kid that
gets all the call the creative control
in the world and I still have to like
listen to studio notes and I've made 50
movies and you know and I've gotta like
recut Miley / you know Louie be me or
whatever and so I think people resented
him and it's like anything and they do
when you resent somebody like that he
has power like you like you we want him
to fail I also think a part of it has to
do with the fact that Citizen Kane was
such a monumental achievement the first
time out of gate that it was impossible
for him to match that level of that
power that came out of out of Citizen
Kane even though his subsequent movies
are all fantastic and of themselves it's
it's like you make them you make the
towering achievement and then it's all
downhill from there I think he always he
always said that it's very difficult to
make your best work first because how do
you how do you how do you follow that
but i think that people unfairly said
that he was some of you who went over
budget and over schedule because
actually if you look at the
documentation he was actually very
frugal and very wasn't this crazy you
know out-of-control genius which makes
the story even more tragic you know one
of the things that always upset me was
that when he was older and still trying
to get
dancing that you know people like
Spielberg would spend you know million
dollars on the Rosebud sled you know it
to buy as a personal memento I came
around which was a lot of money but he
wouldn't help him get movie made so they
admired him and yet they weren't able to
executive-produce Orson Welles's lad may
be his last movie wasn't like he was
asking for zillions of dollars he
remains this tragic figure and and
infinitely interesting because he was
such a brilliant filmmaker because he
had such a command of the medium I mean
they're very few filmmakers where you
feel that they have a complete command
over the medium there's some directors
that are actors directors of some
directors better visual directors the
Sun directors that have no idea how to
edit or you sound and this was clearly a
man who intuitively had this way with
film and all in all its various aspects
so that's why they're so alive although
even ones that fail or interesting
because there's always something going
on I'm wondering with that failure do
you think that's a very common thread
the people self-sabotage because they do
get set up or there is resentment and
they they almost feel guilty maybe it's
funny when you look at people who it's
interesting to look at the film's the
second films of people that have made
monster hits like I've always looked at
light for example William freaking who
like you know had the success of the
French Connection and The Exorcist and
then was basically given again like
carte blanche like okay you're you're
made these monster commercial critical
hits make whatever you want I don't care
how much it costs and he makes a movie
called sorcerer which is this remake of
this of the great Enric liuzhou film
wages of fear about about desperate men
driving nitroglycerin through jungle
with Roy Scheider two studios made it
took two studios to finance sorcerer
nobody knows that movie knowing it and
that's like a gigantic movie and it's
actually a very very good movie but you
get the feeling like why calling it
sorcerer I mean the word sorcerer makes
it sound like it's about wizards and
stuff
and it had Roy Scheider at the top of
his popularity it's a big action
adventure picture with incredible set
pieces and suspense and nobody gave a
nobody saw that movie is like
killed it and the same thing happened
obviously with Michael cimmino you know
it makes deer hunter and then you follow
it with this may be the biggest disaster
of all time Heaven's Gate you know so
there may be is something I think
probably maybe there maybe there's a
degree of self-sabotage your guilt but
there's also this kind of like okay now
I'm going to like now that I have the
power I'm going to make the thing I
always wanted and maybe that thing isn't
necessarily the most commercial thing
which is how Hollywood measures success
so I'm grateful for movies like sorcerer
in Heaven's Gate because you get to see
something realize that wouldn't would
never have been realized had these
directors not made these super popular
movies but I oddly enough these are like
these are like the things that killed
sometimes careers so I don't know I
haven't been haven't been in the
situation yet where I with made
something that I was so successful that
I decided to destroy my own career with
the next film you know maybe hopefully I
get there then I can do that yeah Jack
for anyone interested in studying the
craft of filmmaking what films would you
recommend they sit down and watch over
and over again Wow which films to study
craft well they're so i mean that's like
that's a tough one but i do think you
know we're talking about well it's
important to watch the films that where
you see all the various aspects of film
again cinematography staging of actors
editing sound music where all of these
things are sort of firing on all
cylinders i mean that's the most
practical way rather if you look at you
if you see a ton if you watch movies all
the time then of course you can focus on
certain movies that are like more
performance-based like you're interested
in performance and how to create
naturalistic almost documentary style
performance then you could look like you
know what I'm looking farther than
someone like Mike Lee look at Mike
Leigh's films which again a lot of them
are visually beautiful but there
all about like capturing real moments
between people but if you want to
understand all the components of film
then you have to study people who master
all of these areas so they're a handful
of people who are like you know it's a
ton of them but you know obviously
Alfred Hitchcock comes to mind right
away because this was again somebody who
had complete command over the medium
this wasn't an actor director this
wasn't a visual director only like
Michael Bay this was someone who knew
how to use everything so to watch I say
I tell my students this watch Alfred
Hitchcock from like when he was making
films in England you know like even you
can steam start with the silent films
but even if you start with something
like you know like The Lady Vanishes or
the 39 steps you know which are just as
funny and interesting and visually
stunning as anything you know he made
later or any recent films for that
matter if you watch all Hitchcock you'll
be a better filmmaker like you could sit
down and watch a Hitchcock movie a week
and you watch everything and you'll
watch you know you watch you know
obviously vertigo and rear window and
notorious North by Northwest and psycho
and the birds and and shadow of a doubt
and spelled out you watch all those
movies you'll be a better filmmaker if
you watch Scorsese you know sort of like
soup to nuts if you watch like say from
mean streets on and you take in you know
all of his movies Alice's the variety of
movies Alice's live here anymore and
taxi driver and you know not just as
gangster pictures like Goodfellas and
casino but you take everything in you
again you learn from somebody who cares
about everything that's going on in the
frame picture and sound everything I
think those two I think score stays in
Hitchcock if you're coming in like cold
is a great place to start and then you
can start to realize you know then you
start to see that I mean there's a huge
gamut there's so many filmmakers you
know you can start anywhere think that's
our with Bergman you can start with Ford
you know but I think those two I think
that's the place to really start to get
a grasp that's where you become really
aware of camera and camera movement and
atmosphere and blocking and composition
because they're all couched in very
entertaining pieces of cinema and
they're they're not so much calling
attention to themselves but they're not
end well again and wells for that matter
it's not subtle filmmaking it's very
dynamic filmmaking and that's like a way
of learning when you first see like the
bold strokes and then once you recognize
those things and how they're how they're
being a foul effective they are then you
can start to examine subtler filmmakers
and you can start to recognize those
same techniques being applied in a much
more unobtrusive way for that matter I
think you know it's crazy it's a
difficult question if you want to
include everybody I know it's a core
sawa you know okay all right i would say
Hitchcock Scorsese curse all watch all
those be better filming how important is
it for filmmakers to keep up with the
latest trends in camera technology I
mean has it been a habit of yours to
check out DSLR weekly you know I mean I
think it's important I think it's
important to be aware with what new
tools and toys are out there just
because it there may be a thing that you
want to do that's in your head that
you're not able to execute it's funny
because I was just at the Kubrick
exhibit which totally goes great exhibit
at LACMA Kubrick and I was reader one of
those everything is there you know all
this documentation all these letters and
storyboards and everything so cool one
of things I noticed was there was a
letter from I can't remember who is
producing at the time letter to Kubrick
from a producer friend saying I just saw
this amazing thing it's this device that
enables the camera to be free floating
on an operator and you can follow people
downstairs and up the uphills and the
camera remains stable and I think this
will be an incredible you should check
this thing out and it weighs in who's
talking about basically he was talking
about the Steadicam before was the
Steadicam and it was like and the letter
was Stanley you need to see this because
I think you're going to desert their
shot that you have in your head that you
up to now you couldn't couldn't achieve
but now with this thing you can you know
so in a way I think it's it's really
important because
it helps you realize the things that
that are in your mind better the problem
is is that sometimes that technology is
not affordable like there are millions
of shots that I would do that that I
would like to do that I would do with a
techno crane which is a great piece of
equipment which is essentially a
telescoping arm so like if you wanted to
do a dolly move there were like you know
I'm trying to think it lose where then
really use it well like in the thin red
line there's a lot of shots where
they're like assaulting this kind of
this hill like foliage blowing and
they'll following the troops up the hill
and it's this rock steady sort of
tracking shock where you're tracking you
know with these soldiers as they crawl
this help and you realize well it can't
be a dolly move because how do you delay
dolly track up a mountain and it's not
really a Steadicam shot it's and what it
is it's a telescoping arm so that means
the cameras are an arm that literally
telescopes out like this it gets longer
and longer and you can follow people
that way see if you can do incredible
shot can go through windows that
nobody's gonna be outside a house and
you can be pushing it on the house and
go literally like right through the
window into the living room that's a
super expensive piece of equipment I can
never afford you know down in the low
budget movies that I've made about this
we great for the technocrane but I can't
afford it so then I have to reconsider
or something like that which can also be
fun creatively but for me the the
magazine that I read all the time and I
still read is american cinematographer
american cinematographer which again it
is what it is it sound plates a journal
of summit ography but it just features
whatever is coming out but from the
perspective of the DP and that's really
good for directors because I think all
strong directors essentially need to be
as bright and is informed as their own
DP in order to visualize you'll be in
order to direct the cinematographer and
that moved that magazine every month is
loaded with just like this is the lens
we use this is the this is the piece of
grip equipment we use is lights we use
the include charts so for a film student
or filmmaker it's a great
do we in-depth technical
behind-the-scenes journal and you can
get it anywhere or get a subscription
you can get it online it's a great great
i still refer to that all the time it's
like a so it's a film geeks techno geeks
look at at how movies are made it's
almost like the yeah it's like the
techno geek version of Entertainment
Weekly you know instead of like oh well
this is what she was wearing those who
she was dating it's like this we were
using this particular wide-angle lens
and it was on this you know shot maker
car that we blah blah blah blah so it's
all very technical and what's cool it's
very cool in a recent interview with
filmmaker david o russell i believe he
admitted that the most difficult place
for him as a director was sort of being
in this position where he didn't know
what film is going to make next sort of
unknown territory um have you ever found
yourself in this position and so what
did you do yeah i have i have found
myself not knowing what i should do next
I was never one of these guys I was
everyone these filmmakers and always end
me these guys that had like this I've
got a stack of screenplays behind I got
I got stories for the rest of my life
that I want to make they're all ready to
go like I never I was never prolific
that way as a writer and inevitably I
did and I'm facing it right now really
the movies that I ended up making them
were more personal to me you know like
the handful of movies like the big empty
or Cucaracha or some guy who kills
people one of my last movies whenever i
finish those movies it was never like i
had this thing necessarily on deck that
i was burning to make in other words it
when it was done it was almost like the
one next or okay you know I mean I have
things I want to do but it's it's
interesting I think when you make a
movie that's important it's filling the
space or this hole in your life or this
or this need to figure something out so
you're dealing with it through this
particular project and then it's not
like okay now I just have this other big
thing I need to deal with all move out
of it it doesn't seem to work that way
for me so I right now I know I want to
make a movie Ryan and I Brian Brian and
I want to make it
movie and we've been talking about ideas
since we wrap some guy who kills people
and they're definitely some that are
more propulsive and more interesting
than others but it's not like we've like
we knew like okay we're going to do this
and then we're going to do this it was
like I think part of it has to be about
finding the thing that's necessary to
make in a way I think the best pieces of
work or art come out of something that
is like personally necessary something
you need to like deal with or figure
like I said sort of explore it's not
even about like I want to make a movie
about racism around one movie about it's
about like this is what's going on in my
life this is what's bothering me can i
find this story that somehow articulates
that that's not an easy thing to do if
you are a journeyman director it's you
can just go do on to the next script
whatever is and like I made a movie
after some guy who kills people that was
totally like well we made that mega
shark movie and you could do something
like that and we like you and we know
you can handle it you want to do this
thing and it's like here's a paycheck
and I'm like yeah I like this kind of
thing I'll do it but it's a big it's a
different thing from coming up with that
thing that you need to make you know I
have higher hopes for films that I have
to make than ones that I'm hired to make
because I feel that those are the best
where I can do my best stuff so I
totally understand that void excuse me
or limbo that can occur after you make a
movie I mean look at Kubrick not that
I'm believing up the last thing I'm
doing is comparing myself to him though
I'm saying is that there's probably a
reason why he made so few movies is
because he was carefully weighing what
his next thing was going to be like why
am I making this thing skipper could
have made triple the amount of movies he
made he certainly would have gotten the
funding but he was look at this is a guy
who could make anything most of us are
like okay well if you know like someone
said to me now okay well all that
like trying to search and find which one
I've got a bucket of money here that you
can make a movie but you got to make it
next month I'd be like okay I'll
suddenly how the inspiration I know
exactly
I'm going to be so Kubrick was in a
position where he could have made any
movie he will want to almost at any
point I mean after he made Spartacus or
2001 he could make anything you want
people are like clamoring and he spent
years between projects because for
whatever reason his process was I've got
to find the perfect thing to do I think
that that may be part of the neurosis of
the creative person is trying to figure
out what you're going to paint next
unless you're just brimming i wish i was
just brimming with you know ideas but
you know i think it's a different type
of personality what is your process for
all about liking you taking long walks
and the forest concept by me or just
observing people in daily life it what
do you do when you're in that space um
yeah I don't know I don't know mr. like
writers block necessarily but it is sort
of like that I mean in the case of
working with Ryan on the next on the
follow up movie to some guy who kills
people it's about us kind of finding the
project that we both feel in other words
I guess it would be slightly different
if I was just sitting down and writing
something because I could say okay right
this is what's on my mind I'll see if I
can I'm feeling you know whatever I'm
feeling so I'm let me try to find
something that fits that movie with Ryan
because when we had such an interesting
collaboration even though some guy who
kills people and the script was so I was
so sort of wedded to it I was so like
this is the thing I need to make you
know Ryan is went through his own
process to make to write death thing I
wasn't there during the writing of that
movie i came in at the end when it was
already sort of realized ryan has to go
through his own process of him fine so
not only am I like in that lindos he is
to you know he's trying to find thing so
sometimes he'll throw out an idea just
working it out like what about this
thing and I'll be like oh this is
fantastic this is exactly what I want to
do but he may not be as crazy about it
as another idea which I'm not so much
into so there's this weird sort of
process we're going through now or it's
like what about this
can we show each other what's
interesting in these ideas that we're
floating about i don't know i think that
the only way to get through the process
is to I think sometimes it's helpful
doing like for example trailer hitch
it's helpful doing trailer it's helpful
doing small things I think even doing an
interview doing a really short it
doesn't have to be a short film it could
just be like a one minute long thing
where you go out and shoot something I
think the more that you can sort of
exercise that muscle that filmmaking
muscle and actually go out and try some
things like for example like my my
sister-in-law's had a birthday and I'm
never really good at coming up with
presents for Brad you don't know what to
buy anybody in a I can't write a card
but I can't make these little like like
almost like South Park style animations
that I make into a card you know and
that is a creative like making it like
spending a couple hours making out like
a little animated card for my
sister-in-law is a really good way of
like oiling up lubing up the gears so I
think a right like they'll say a writer
writes like the important things if
you're a writer you get up and you write
even if you don't know what you're
writing about just to kind of because
chances are if you just keep doing this
thing it is the equivalent of taking a
long walk in the woods it's like you're
shooting or you're typing while you're
doing it fix something will come out a
word or phrase an image will come and
then it'll be like hopefully that'll
trigger the larger the larger thing I
think that's a way to do it otherwise
all i do is brewed or worry if you just
worry we're going on like nothing comes
from that I've done enough of that I do
that anyway so I think it's important to
just almost like shoot it out or type it
out you know because it's out there it's
just you've got to arrive at it and
sitting about it worrying about it isn't
going to get you there necessarily also
I should be meditating more I learned a
trick what's on really trick as a whole
lifetime it's a whole life experience
but like one of the things when I was
hunting for ideas was I learned about
David Lynch and and transyl then
Transcendental Meditation you know TM
which is this whole other thing but like
one of the reasons that one of the
reasons why David Lynch is such a
proponent of meditating is that that's
where the ideas surface
the other dudes calm your mind down so
that you're not like all the days
isn't spinning through your mind then
the things that are naturally important
to you the idea of being with things
that are naturally interesting will
bubble up and then ideas come from that
you know so that's another thing that I
need to continue to do I did started
doing it actually around Thomas making
mega shark vs giant octopus doing
meditation and it really helped a lot of
things came out of that so since
everybody's process is different but
it's it certainly is a process I wish it
was a faster one so believe you've
launched trailer hitch under the
umbrella of cinefix yes is that right
when you tell us what roles cinefix is
played and what impact you've had on a
success so far well cinefix is the
premium youtubechannel dedicated to film
or basically it's it's it's a channel
it's dedicated to movie lovers and also
filmmakers and the idea is to create
programming that's going to appeal to
you know movie geeks like myself and
also people maybe who make their own
movies and so it's like anything it's
like trying to come up with material
that appeals that'll speak to that
viewer and so we have a whole bunch of
different kind of shows i mean the tube
sort of like trailer hitch is sort of
like is definitely more of a comedy
based observational sort of comedy show
you know but it's funny it was born out
of like the fact that trailers for
movies that are coming out are sort of
like available to us that we want to
promote what's coming out but it's sort
of even though we just put trailers up
that's not really adding any kind of
editorial editorial voice to it so that
so I thought it would be great to sort
of and that's what really would be vison
button Mike Judge was basically like I'm
at MTV we have all these videos running
them anyway why don't we stick these two
crazy losers on top of it and have them
like talk about it and that's
essentially that the idea behind trailer
hitch is to have like two different sort
generations of movie lover one slightly
younger play by myself and one slightly
older play by Allan Havey and
and so that's where that idea came out
of but we also have badass digest which
is devin faraci successful website which
is really all about movies and movie
trivia and movie facts and I almost want
to say like you know almost like fanboys
cinema where you're dealing with with
with with very specific genre films and
and very detail-oriented very much
something that speaks to the movie geek
when thought which I consider myself one
up and now Devon goes out and he
basically host this show where he brings
his website to life where we'll go and
sit down with ryan Johnson the director
of looper in Bob burns basement and Bob
Burns's like the foremost archivist of
all great cinema sci-fi and horror props
like he has all the props from all the
great movies he has you know all the
alien Jim Cameron's aliens and he has
you know gizmo from gremlins and he has
you know the American Werewolf in London
and he has he has the original King Kong
armature you know Peter Jackson key so
we will go to a place like that and show
people like wow look at all this great
stuff look at this man sit down
interview this man who's preserved all
this stuff and then at the same time
will maybe bring ryan Johnson who
directed looper who's also a geek and
he'll see this world for the first time
and then we'll talk to him about looper
and time travel movies in front of like
the original time machine which bob has
like the original George pal you know
broad Taylor time machine so it's like
it's trying to bring these sort of like
and I use this term lovingly you know
film geek culture sort of to life and so
we were doing a whole bunch of shows
like that hopefully we will end up doing
script it shows as well but it's a it's
we're we're brand new you know we're a
brand new channel and we're just I'm
just trying to get out stuff that I
think stuff that I would like to see you
know and I think that's the only thing I
can do is try to create programming that
I think you know I would hopefully want
to sit down and watch and and then maybe
people will also you know watch it watch
it didn't take an interest but it's
weird trying to nab
that whole space and it's not easy it's
like saying well let's just make a bunch
of programs you know that's that's
really we also have been Lions coming
and hosting a show called screen addict
which is sort of like a show that sort
of everything that's going on in the
week and film so it's a very active it's
a very active channel or constantly
producing you know so it's it's
interesting very hectic like a newspaper
like putting on a newspaper Jack how has
independent film evolved since you
started and where do you see it heading
well it's a good question I always felt
like when I started to make my films
independent movies which were probably
the early 90s was sort of like the in a
way it sort of the tail end of a of the
first wave of independent cinema in
other words like when I was in film
school in the 80s that's when you
started to see you know Jim Jarmusch
really starting to make you know waves
and Spike Lee and and Hal Hartley and
all these kind of it was like sort of
like the first wave of independent and
then like in the middle 90s it sort of
became much more commercialized as
people Studios realized it's like
co-opting it's like anything it's like
when they realize that oh you can make a
movie four hundred million dollars and
they can make a ton of money well let's
like do that you know so you sort of
corporatized and it became a different a
different world and I became a star
driven world you know we're now sudden
like somebody calls you know little miss
sunshine an independent movie and it's
like well you know if it's you know if
it's over a million dollars in Greg
Kinnear and now in our commander in your
movie it's not early and you know I mean
you can call it an independent movie I
mean look who's that Sundance which was
supposed to be you know what it was
supposed to be it's like none of those
movies are like don't have not have
stars or or even already have
distributors so that's a different
that's a that I think that it changed I
think what's interesting is now that
more people are able to make movies and
because you can self distribute on
YouTube and so forth that that's really
hopeful because it used to be like you
made your movie and if you didn't get a
distributor than you know what I saw now
as many people as you can get it you can
see it in a very clean pristine
form so I mean a lot of people talked
about that that's that's that's nothing
new I don't know what's going to happen
I don't know if people are going to I
don't think people are going to make
that same jump anymore like everybody
thought well make a little movie and
then I'll become a big i'll become
Steven Spielberg I don't know if that
necessarily happens anymore I think
there's just too many filmmakers and
there's too many technically proficient
filmmakers so where it's going i don't
know i think there'll be more
independent movies there's certainly
more de pute independent movies made
which is great the trick is always going
to be distribution and it's like musics
like weird there's a million great bands
out there how do I know where to find
them unless somebody it goes back to
your question about like how do you get
people to click on your thing I think
you just hope that somebody sees it and
that one person passes it and that next
person passes and maybe the next person
who passes it too has a blog with a lot
of people following and then it just
sort of disseminates but I don't know I
I would love to see I think because more
is getting made the chances are that
there's more good stuff out there system
now it's going to be a question of
somebody hopefully pointing me in the
direction and saying hey you should
check this out I'm stealing a Hollywood
Reporter question here but what would
you say to a 22 year old Jack Perez in
2012 uh what would I tell them so you
get ready because you're going to get
your ass kicked all up and down the
street for about 20 years so you better
use you know you better be ready to get
beat up you know because I mean that's
nothing new I mean that everybody does
uh I've I told myself what I was going
to go through I wonder I don't know i
don't know if i don't think i wouldn't
Nelson would not have done it but it's
like
I just think it's a you know it's a
tough business and and and it helps you
in the beginning to be ignorant because
that naivety protects you that sort of
like hopefulness protects you and it
actually enables you to create stuff
which is great but you also have to be
ready for the reality of the business
which is that you know there's a lot of
people out there all trying to do the
same thing and you know even if you're
talented that doesn't mean that you're
going to be rewarded and you have to
find a way to I would say to a young
filmmaker that it's important to define
in your mind going into it what success
means that's the thing that I think I
missed messed up i associated success
with you know whether I was going to get
hired again whether if I made it
independent movie and then a studio
hired me to make a movie that means that
I'm successful that means I'm approved
or that if my movie got picked up by a
distributor or got picked up by Sundance
or a festive a big festival that is
success because that means that I've
been like knighted or stamped that's
like the biggest mistake anybody can
make because success that's subjective I
mean who are these people at Sundance
that are deciding what gets in who are
these people I mean they're not like
these mystical magical because people
and they have their own agendas and that
doesn't mean that you're not as good as
that all it means is that they decided
to pick somebody else for whatever
reason and the same thing goes with
distribution you can have your movie
done and you could it could be great and
somebody distribute some piece of crap
thing because they think that's going to
make more money there's nothing to do
with the quality of your work and I made
certain I i I'd certainly had times
where I was like you know down on myself
because I didn't tick these boxes that i
had had set for myself and it's
perfectly fine to set you know to be
ambitious and I've never stopped being
ambitious but don't I feel it's
important not to judge yourself based on
things that you can't control think it's
more important to ask like when you're
taking criticism from somebody it's more
important to know like who am i
listening to you know like I would much
rather take criticism from someone
respect than just some like test market
of schmoes that des I you know that's
that's where you can kind of go off the
rails so don't be so hard on yourself I
guess is the is the thing I would say